the girag and experience okay do they
have a list of enhanced breasts for
women's MMA um no II this I'll need to
ask somebody this is this is too long of
a google search I need to call up a Big
John McCarthy or yeah you can't can't
kick the bottle but you can grab it it
is weird like you guys grab yeah guys do
what they call oil check excuse me when
oil check is sometimes middle the
grappling the guy will literally have
his fingers deep in a guy's asshole
just digging in there and you know it
forces the guy to move forces gotta move
in a way to get away from that grip and
I don't I don't think it's in I don't
think it's illegal it's not I don't
think it's illegal in wrestling either
I'm gonna start making MMA butt plugs no
that would just shove something deeper
in your ass you have to have like a
protection but what if you do a little
at but the problem is you need movement
like you're needed you're asking to be
able to move so anything that you do
that would like protect your asshole
would be restrictive it would be like it
would restrict your ability to move left
and right it would be a miserable yeah
yeah I would mess with your athleticism
to oil checks legal what if it's like
like this though like if it's a lie
that's just a button will enter duck
down no they explain dickin things in
your ass I need to find out if this is
yeah oh so what about this one oh I
gotta go to the bathroom I care that
here's one where he gets I checked yeah
dudes do this all the time yeah
Christoph's is in ski so I was on camera
he says oops wait this is uh Rudy Ana
yeah I even said something on the end of
it um one guy actually got a rape charge
from a wrestling match apparently what
when was this
seventeen-year-old Jerome hunt faces 21
counts of rape and attempted rape each
count carries with him up to 25 years in
prison
Hunt's lawyer Mike Butler crank claims
that complaints came from fellow parker
wrestlers who were simply victims of a
legitimate wrestling move Butler just
filed a motion to move the case to
juvenile court on that court document he
lays out a
a lot of information presented to the
grand jury before they indicted hunt on
the rape charges while he's indicted on
the rape charges Wow
former state champion wrestler Jerome
hunts lawyer says that all but two of
the incidents reported happened in the
Parker high school wrestling room before
the practice during last year's
wrestling session before practice before
practice before practice rape yeah it
possibly came from a wrestling move
called a butt drag or skinning okay
before practice what is this black
dragon before practice it's not
something illegal or not being taught
it's being taught all over one accuser
even testified to a grand jury I didn't
take it as a sexual move I took it as
him just messing around well huh who
charged him then a prude hmm this is
interesting because that is the oil
check is like a legitimate wrestling
move if that's what he's doing
it's like people have been doing whether
or not you think they should be able to
do that I don't think they should be
able to do that but people have been
doing that for a long time like an
actual legitimate wrestling like but
look up oil check right find a video for
oil check wrestling because that's
something that guys have done like for a
long-ass time I mean I would even say
that's like gladiator days I'm sure they
did that well it's not the most
effective way to control a person so
it's not like something that someone
does for a long time or on a regular
basis it's just when you're in a
wrestling match of someone what you're
trying to do is win and if you spend
time fingering is but you could have
been doing other things that would
actually get you to win the match so
it's not like something that comes up
all the time I call that a Friday whoa
but um some people uh you know some
people who don't know wrestling who
found out that this guy's oil checking
people and you know maybe being a dick
about it
hey Johnny's oil checking people
know fine just what is this no no no not
checking the oil crisis oil oil check
off his image we'll check wrestlers
checking beaches just listen google oil
check wrestling that was about it
I'm gonna but drag you so you ain't safe
yeah yeah see not a maroon 5 songs I see
she's a totally legal see how he's doing
this and the referee is not getting
angry at him and no one's going to jail
see this is it is actually a legal
wrestling move that guy putting his
hands in that guy's asshole like that is
totally legal not only is it totally
legal it's so common who made this video
like who it was like you know what I'm
gonna go today like I said you it's it's
common but it's not the most common
thing like wrestling it is all about
those yes it makes sense it's not the
best way to control a guy all the time
though so when it does come up guys do
it but it's not like the only way to do
it and it's not like if you if you
concentrate on that when you should be
doing something else
you're gonna lose the wrestling match so
it's not he's what he's doing is using
it as a whole he's literally trying to
grapple by holding on to the guy like
that he's not necessarily pleasurable he
might be sexual we might also be trying
to inflict pain and discomfort yeah but
it's been going on forever
oh those damn oil checkers so to take
this one kid and calm a rapist was that
stop but the other thing was then said
door before practice that's a problem
with the before practice that that
disturbs me like we have been waiting
away in it like hours before practice
like five minutes before practice or
you're warming up you're in the locker
room like hey check this out you going
over techniques like what exact what
exactly is going on and how many counts
did say like it was a just one person
think they said like 40 Jesus yeah it's
sorta people or 40 40 edges well I'll
read it again well I shouldn't talk
about this kid by the way this was a
several years ago okay 2006 actually but
uh 21 counts Wow yeah that if you know I
don't know what that kid did so I'm just
talking out of my ass but if the kid did
what's in those videos you better go
watch those videos because there's
videos of people doing that but drag or
oil check forever
it's been going on for as long as it's
been wrestling it's just not the most
effective thing to do always not in
every man
but shits pretty fucking common yeah you
know minute but plugs
that doesn't help dude stupid idea it's
just gonna go deeper in and you bleed OH
so I'm gonna stop the guy from holding
onto it I get a little tail on the oh
good idea
make it a decorative but pull that out
and the guy gets embarrassing to tap
them yeah
come be like a loud pop Oh pop cuz I
sorry about that uh okay take that yeah
well there's me did I hear that um Brock
Lesnar's thinking about coming back to
the UFC he adds bullshit oh it is yeah
it's bullshit so there's one hype story
where they were trying to hype it up
because the WWE was saying that Brock
Lesnar was in Vegas they made a big
announcement but it's really just a
publicity move to talk about Brock
Lesnar's wrestling appearance so there
was a little bit of hype on that some
guys tweeting me that the butt drag does
not go into the butthole um yes it does
sir sometimes the butt track does not go
into it but yeah they're saying it said
there's a nerve back there no it's
pulling yeah you're right
but tell me that dudes don't sometimes
put fingers in people's assholes hey man
if I can for sure do because I've had it
happen so shut your mouth if I haven't
tell me yeah don't tell me that oil
checks don't go in your asshole I've had
it out snaky creepy fingers do the oil
drag you want to rat on a ground well
it's not like you're gonna like just rub
it like a round you know it's there you
go you go in it's not like oh I'm sorry
there's well this I've lied to me
there's different people look at this
there's a nice one right there that's a
yeah that is definitely definitely
now those win is that Bobby Lee yes it's
Bobby Lee Oh a woman oh it might be
Felicia oh I don't know who that is
the might be my friend Felicia she's a
badass grappler look at this one she oh
those that's no I know that is not right
these are the that guy's an asshole yeah
that bit is that's the oil wrestling
they're like Russian oil risk Turkish
Turkish and Turkish Wars yeah Jesus
Christ oh yeah yeah anybody who says it
doesn't go in your asshole shut it he's
clearly looking at that and just being
like yeah you fuck it it's well you know
it doesn't always go in sometimes it
just hits the taint sometimes it's just
a guy would hurt that would hurt had a
good grip on the upper deck it doesn't
actually
in the asshole he's just pulling the lid
up pulling the lid up on the macaroni
and cheese container just get the steam
out
yeah just Tupperware in that
motherfucker but sometimes it goes in
the asshole there's a lot of fucking
butthurt wrestling guys out there that
are arguing with me right now on Twitter
we just showed you photos you fucks
you're in denial and there's a lot of
guys who have had their assholes finger
who were like thank you Joe for speaking
up bullshit didn't go mouse you can't go
in dude it's a trap
my assholes like a bank vault nothing's
getting in you might be knocking on the
door but you cannot got my door does
that mean you sleep in my house no it
does not mean you sleep in my house
you're just not gonna my no you can't
get in I think it's time if you have had
your butthole invaded by failure
tomorrow
and so's the brown starfish of security
it's nothing nothing gets through its
tight like like that fucking went event
horizon when would it open up the time
that's my favorite scary movie ever
it's game that's my favorite scary movie
of all time I'm so glad you said that
fucking good scary that's a terrifying
movie whoo yeah the idea that they run
into hell who don't stay mortal sea is
enough Brian enough of pee and uff what
are you showing more guys with hands up
these assholes I think we get it yeah
prank yeah it happens wrestling fans I
know you don't like to believe it
happens but it happens oh yeah that was
real too it's all real that's different
that's just two men standing their
ground with their lips locked and trying
to gain an advantage making Valentine's
Day plan by the way the white guy won
what guy won that one so much to dismay
of black people everywhere should have
but second much dismay of Anderson Silva
fans much dismay of people don't like
wrestling or but checks oil checks drags
blood tracks I'm sure Chris Weidman has
been oil checked some time in his life
last name like white men's how you make
an animal like that why ha ha Wow how
dare you how dare you what is this
parody can we play your parody video
yeah sure if it was it it's called not
looking not looking
yeah as fake Brian stylet what Jesus why
believes everything Twin Towers fucking
black helicopters that's just naked
[Music]